all right hello everybody so I'm Paul I
am a senior data scientist with h-e-b
before that I was actually nearby at
Caltech doing acoustics research ended
up pulling the cord to leave grad school
early but still still like to come by I
see some people um I will say towards
towards the final year of my grad school
I was kind of looking at ways to to
build my skills make myself more ready
for industry and I have this grand idea
of like hey you know we all have this
code that we're working together in the
lab we're emailing files to each other
this is a horrible idea let's establish
again repo and I set it up and nobody
else use it but thanks to the magic that
you guys are all attending my tutorial
we're gonna start building a code base
for an experimental lab together so if
you would like to navigate to github
ends LP WJ gets PDL a 2019 I would
actually we're gonna have a few
exercises where I'm gonna interact with
some of you who here has get set up on
their computer would be willing to be a
guinea bit guinea pig and it is able to
connect to the Wi-Fi if you have any
takers
all right overview of what we're going
to be going on largely the work is
collaborating with others so merge
conflicts creating code branches code
review pull requests opening issues
depending on time we can also do some
recovering from errors it gets quick
raise of hands from the audience here
who here is a beginner to get ok we've
got a few I'm not going to go to a
really into the beginning from there I
will recommend if you'd like a good
tutorial software carpentry has some
excellent online material and all their
material is largely get by yourself so
this this lecture is going to be kind of
an extension of the lectures that
software carpentry has as as far as more
advanced topics that we're going to be
going not really going to be going over
rebasing briefly touch on that but it's
kind of a harder topic to get through
get hooks get tags fairly
straightforward especially get tags but
less relevant the dot git ignore file is
fantastically useful and I left my
sticky notes at home I am going to I am
going to ask you to start with the
exercises and just so
for those here who here has run into a
merge conflict
who here hates running into a merge
conflict they are absolutely no fun so
let me show you the kind of base that
we've got here we are building out some
code for our acoustics lab and right now
we're starting with just got a this
folder here instruments we have some
calibrations so we have some four
sensors and they'll give us a force
voltage results we also have a bit of
code that will take these calibrations
and give us a nice little plot here so
so if I want to do
Python force sensors code and I give it
one of our four sensors this
beautiful blot our goal as we as we work
through this is we want to extend this
to the microphones code that we have we
want to be able to plot some transfer
functions for these which is it's kind
of a similar thing of just how live the
microphone is for different frequencies
and we want to have some basic tests for
this code because testing is a lovely
thing and would have saved me much time
many years ago as a start of getting
tests that's a start of testing let's
add a dummy force sensor here so we
would like to have kind of a fake force
sensor you know it's a little hard for
me to predict between these forces
voltages well it's going to be a force
for if I have 15 Newtons what's the
voltage gonna be something around 1.1 or
something I can't tell so we're gonna
create it we're gonna add a dummy sensor
here and use that to generate some
things so so sir are you except you have
number one on six who's number one okay
the fellow in the back
so exercise is so you're gonna had you
are taking it upon yourself to add this
little bit of code to the repo and
because this is a private repository I
am going to need to add you as a
collaborator
[Music]
all right so what's your github username
sorry all right so you should be getting
an email so is it fair to say step one
is to make the connection between your
collaborators with so you sent him an L
in a perfect world what would really
happen here so in a perfect world we if
you're part of an organization they will
generally add you as part of the part of
the get repository and that will be
handled for you the other alternative is
generally if you're working with an
open-source project you'll you'll
generally have to be interacting with
them a lot to be added as a collaborator
but what you'll what you'll do if you
feel like you need to make changes to
something as you'll create a fork and
we'll go over that a little bit later in
the session you'll make the changes in
your fork which is your own personal
version of that repository and then
you'll move the changes from your
personal fork back to the main branch so
we all get to that so in our situation
here we got stuck with the email right I
just checked my email including my spam
and I haven't received it I just tried
to editing it online just in the github
editor yeah it makes you it makes you
generate your own fork yeah I'll put
this on my own but much appreciate for
you for you to trying and taking this so
I will make
so I've added this fake this fake sensor
here and I've done this on github my
computer doesn't actually know about the
change that I've made and even though
theoretically I'm adding I'm editing the
code both if I'm doing it in Visual
Studio or I'm doing it on github the
these are two different computers that
are going to have two different views of
what's going on if I go to if I go to my
terminal log I don't know about this
change I've made on github
if I was smart every time I was gonna
make changes I would do git fetch smart
I would do git fetch origin/master
and download the latest changes I can
tell you I forget that a lot of times
other people forget that a lot of times
and if you were working at the same time
as somebody else you might not even know
about these changes coming coming
through I will say this this is one
reason I'm a very big proponent of using
a git graphical interface like source
tree source tree or vs code or something
they can be set so automatically like
every few minutes
look at get look at github look at
bitbucket whatever and see is there
anything new for me to download so this
is source screens telling me hey you
have something you need to pull but
we're gonna cause a merge conflict so
I'm copying this code over here but I'm
doing a completely other version of this
save this add and commit everything
looks fine until I try and push and then
we get the error message we all know and
love
okay get pull automatic merge conflict
thankfully vs code Adam both of these
will actually give you a nice highlight
of the things that that fixed and this
is a relatively easy thing to see I can
see two versions are the same thing I'll
know what to pick life is easy when it's
you know you're just picking a couple
lines or you're having to you're having
to just kind of concatenate one set of
code with another set of code what's
really hard is a having this kind of pop
up unexpected every time you're adding
you're adding code and be
if you if you're making much bigger
changes trying to track down everywhere
where things are gonna fail merge
conflicts are drama the real goal that
that you want to have is let's let's
keep them controlled and let's
anticipate what needs to happen there
isn't ultimately there's not gonna be
any substitute for communicating with
other people that if you're working with
them on a basis of code but by using
branches and Forks it's a lot easier to
know like oh I anticipate we're gonna
see a conflict here let me talk with
this other person or you know at least I
can work on my code and at the very end
I can resolve all the merge conflicts so
who here has used branches before show
of hands
so about maybe a quarter of the room the
basic way you can sort of think about
branches are there alternate versions of
the code I will I'll create a branch and
I can edit the code all I want in that
branch but as soon as you know anybody
else working on the master branch or
anything else they're not gonna see the
changes that I am making this branch so
this makes it very easy for me to do my
work somebody else can do their other
work and then once I'm satisfied with
the changes I've made with my branch
then you'll merge the branches you'll
take the code changes you've made in
your branch and put it back into master
or dev or whatever is kind of the main
working working draft you have and
that's good that's how you add code to
the main thing so if you're working
alone this is kind of the process you do
your on master you have your commits and
you just have one commit after another
after another the basic cycle you're
going to do with branches is instead of
adding all your changes to master
you open a branch you make your changes
there you merge them back to master why
go through all this rigmarole somebody
else is doing the same thing around the
same time and you know this thing any
changes that are getting made here this
guy doesn't need to know or worry about
it and then when we make this merge down
here it's gonna be much more controlled
and generally github bitbucket get loud
they will warn us ahead of time
hey there's gonna be merge conflicts and
so you can you can anticipate what's
gonna happen and you can make all your
you can sort of save dealing with the
merge conflict so if your last so why
are we branching you know we're stepping
working out with others without stepping
on toes if you have this idea of like oh
I want to change things up may I have
this experiment I want to do great you
create a branch play around with the
code as much as you want it's not gonna
affect anything else the most important
thing is this whole process of branching
is what really enables code review when
you try and merge the code in you'll
open what's called a pull request and
we'll get to that in just a second and
that's gonna be a step where people are
gonna look at the changes you've made
and critiquing I am a very firm believer
in code review there was research by
Emmy Fagan 1976 our four-hour code
review is the most effective use of time
there's some caveats we'll get to that
in a little bit if you're working in an
industry the earlier you catch your bugs
the cheaper it is and this is this is
some real research that smart bear did
it is by a factor of 10 sometimes how
much cheaper it is to catch bugs earlier
in the process if you're working in
academia replace cost wit with time and
frustration specs catching these things
early makes everybody's life much ease
it's also a great way you know you're
collaborating with other people other
people understand the code that you're
writing it's a it's an opportunity for
you to improve your skills and help
other people improve their others
improve their skills you know 100
percent I'm a firm believer and the use
of code review
so the basic cycle that we're gonna do
is we will create a branch go through
the through the get things we have we're
gonna open a pull request and we're
gonna ask people hey these are the
changes I've made they might say
looks good ready to go and that in that
case you can merge it more often they'll
say hey can you fix XY and Z and you'll
just you'll go you'll address these
things there's any merge conflicts will
resolve them and then things will
resolve okay how do we actually do this
yet as of 2.23 decided hey let's not use
check out for four different unrelated
concepts it's amazing years ago do you
think all the computers are going to use
have upgraded to get to point two three
unfortunately so if you if you are using
two point two three the way you kind of
switch around branches is healthily
named against which otherwise get check
out is kind of the universal way of
creating a branch let me actually open
the journal so get branch you can see
what branches we have gets which FMC new
branch
switch so you can see we're on this new
branch thing here if I need to switch
back to master if I need to delete this
branch either you'll have the small D
you do that if it complains you can do
Big D and that will fully delete
everything if you need to load a branch
from your remote repository so if we
look at github here we can actually see
I have three other branches here so we
have this exercises dummy Mike branch we
have four sensors unit test again my
computer doesn't know about these so I
would have to tell and that's how I tell
myself no computer there's another
branch again source tree vs code or what
not these these tools can do this for
you which is very helpful
sorry yeah I'm having to enter them in
either there is a I believe there is a
fetch option I want to say it's - t and
I'm probably wrong but there's there's a
way to basically tell your computer look
at the remote server and tell me all the
branches that are available alternately
if I go to source tree so this GUI is
going to tell me hey we've got these 3
exercise branches here and I apologize
this is I don't know how to improve
increase the size of the text here but a
good G a good GUI program will actually
tell you all the remote branches there
and if I wanted to download the branch
to my computer I can just double click
on it and it will tell me hey you want
to check out this this branch and create
a local branch based on it so that's
generally gonna be the best way to go
about doing this talk about deleting
branches naming branches kind of like
naming variables it's good to be
informative so new branch is not a good
name new Piazza caliper calibrations is
is great one trick you can do with
creating branches is you can have kind
of this you can pretend like you're
creating folders so you do something
slash something else if you actually
look at what we have in source tree it's
tree I have three branches that are
named exercises slash something it is
basically treating the saying like oh
you want to create a folder like this
and so you know it's just it's
to slash it's just a straight a
character in our string but certain gy
clients will tell you like hey this is
you know this is a good way to obviously
you want to kind of collate all these
things together and even if you just
have a lot of branches and you're just
looking through them alphabetically
that's another good way to be able to
sort like hear all the hear all the
branches that deal with you know this
nature paper we're writing because we're
publishing to nature or something if you
work with the ticket system so if you're
using Trello or JIRA or something like
that I also really like to include the
ticket name as a part of the branch
that's a very helpful way to be able to
if somebody's like what's going on with
this branch why are you doing this they
can say oh well this this deals with
ticket one six five
they'll go to Trello and they'll say
okay this is this is the context I need
to know for for the retrieve created as
an example of kind of this there's a few
different ways I use branches the most
basic thing I use is one branch per
ticket so you know this is the I don't
know I'm adding in unit tests for this
this code function I have a ticket for
that here's my branch for it I do it
it's done if you have a really big
project that's going to involve a lot of
work I'll create a branch for that big
project and then I'll create little
branches off of that branch and that
will let you know then I can do like
lots of code code reviews and whatnot
for the little branches and once all my
work for that big project is done then I
can merge that whole thing back in and
that's a good way to kind of cut up the
work and let people go through it
through things step by step so that
that's a good thing to do I mentioned
what off tests another thing that that
you'll hear people doing
if you're in a software context where
you you create releases of code so let's
say you have to you have some like
really important code that you knows all
the backend for you know a big web
service or something what people might
do there is they'll say okay well every
week we're gonna cut a release branch
and the release branch is what goes on
to our servers and so we have a very
clear idea of like this is the code
that's running this week and next week
Tuesday we're gonna cut a new release
branch and deploy it if you need to make
small small hot fixes to that you can
but that way you know you you don't have
kind of a working draft of code for a
really important fundamental code that
everyone is using you have like this is
a set you know this is this is our
release branch this is what's going on
the server's it might also have cases
where you know if you're doing a really
big important thing you'll have people
doing quality assurance on it so you'll
have the dev branch which is kind of
your working copy and then every so
often the QA folks will will take the
stuff from the dev branch to the master
branch and they'll test everything there
and make sure nothing breaks and then
from there you'll they'll cut things to
the release branch so you can get pretty
complicated branch structures depending
on your needs
my advice there has just use as much
structure as is reasonable you know
small small branches back to master if
you're only working with a few other
people that's fine thank you very much
but if you're working on something where
if this goes down uh-oh you know the
hospital system is going to crash or
whatnot you're gonna want to have a lot
more structure in place to make sure
things do not break but very good
question thank you can I should
rethink chop does anybody else have any
questions on well because what we've
covered so far I'm working in a branch
and waiting on a code review I need to
sort of stop working on that branch then
I want to continue some work that builds
off that further do branch off the
branch and is there trouble bringing
that back together or kind of where
should I do that continue to work while
I wait on a code review you can branch
off the branch and then so you'll take
you have the branch that's undergoing
code review you're fixing things and as
you're as you're fixing things in that
branch you can merge the changes from
from the the branch under code review to
the new branch you have and just grab
that all the changes that are getting
made there so a little bit ago we ran a
we ran a little line of code to to plot
to plot things nowhere is it documented
how this how we do this so I will go
through the process you know creating a
branch check out the old term so we're
the new branch see here so I will edit
my code
so I've made my changes get Ad commit
and the only difference that I'm making
here is instead of get push origin
master don't you typically do i do get
push origin name of the branch asks for
my password it'll tell me new branch has
been created we can go over to github we
can see page the new branch and very
helpfully github get lab bitbucket
they all generally have an idea of like
hey you pushed a new branch to me you
probably want to open a pull request
which we'll get to in a little bit so if
I was if we were gonna edit this code
together I'd click this button but we're
gonna try another exercise so who has
the page labeled number two okay let me
see if I can let me try and add you as a
collaborator and you'll see if this
works so what's your github username dy
yes yep
great so you should be hopefully you
should be getting an email and the email
would have it will have a button for you
to click yeah I'm also not seeing the
email okay then I will then we'll move
forward
sorry no unfortunately experiment love
this movement I have created a branch
for this so we can pretend that you've
added this code it is here and exercise
microphone code so if we look at this
has dummy like we'll see we we have the
code for this
I mentioned Forks a little bit ago
basically you know a branch is an
alternate version of the code that lives
in the same repo a fork is a version of
the code that lives in a different video
so most commonly you're gonna be forking
the code to your owner own account and
you can say like so this is this is a
branch class generally as I said if you
work with open big
open source projects they don't want you
know a it's to create branches as you
can see you need to be added as a
collaborator which is not is not so
intuitive and B they don't want people
just kind of cluttering putting all
sorts of nonsense in the branch
so with what they'll you'll do instead
if you want to create a form is you can
click this fork button up here it will
copy the branch to your personal to your
account you can branch you can make all
the changes you want there and you can
merge changes you make in your personal
Fork back to the main version of code so
you know if I wanted to work on Matt pot
lid here I'm gonna go up I'm gonna say
I'm not gonna have the permission to
create a branch here but I can create a
fork I'm gonna fork it to my account
this will create a copy and then I can
make all the changes that I want in this
fork and if I if I had an idea of how to
improve matplotlib or something else I
do the do the work here and then I would
merge the changes from the fork in this
repository back to the main map pot live
repository another another common case
where you might be using Forks is let's
say you have a tutorial here at PI data
or somewhere else that you really like
so I was listening to Danielle Brooks PI
torch tutorial I want to take his code
and I want to make lots of changes with
it as I miss around with things but I
don't want to screw up his version of
the code I can fork his his changes to
my repository and then I can play around
with this tutorial material as much as I
want and it's not going to affect the
work that Daniel has done the one thing
that gets a little tricky with Forks is
you need to tell get about both the
original
posit or e so matplotlib matplotlib and
your personal version of the of your
repository so if big changes happen in
the big repository you can download
those as opposed to downloading it from
you from your personal version the term
to search for is called get is get sent
up stream so you're making your changes
okay this looks good I want somebody to
review it and I want them to say great
let's add this to take a pull request
and merge requests are two terms for the
same thing get lab uses merge requests
it's a more accurate term github has
about 50% mark market share so everybody
calls them pull requests same thing
though you're taking the your code that
you've done and you're bringing it back
to the original master or whatever other
branch you like so I added this
instruction mystic calibrations I can
either click on this pull requests tab
up here or it's helpless saying hey you
want to create a pull request and as I
create a pull request I'm gonna say for
reviewers tag somebody else as we look
over your pull request
assignees is gonna be like this is the
person who whose job it is to kind of
massage everything through this
so once I've added the helpful title and
a helpful description of what's going on
I get will say like hey can I merge can
I not merge in this case I have no merge
conflicts so this would be ready to
merge and then anybody else looking at
this they can look at the commits so
they can see the changes I've made I've
made one commit they can also look at it
per file and all the changes that that
have been made and as you're looking at
these things for example you can add
comments so I can either go to the files
change or specific commits I can click
on these buttons here and I can say
comment but also just add various
comments here and so this is the main
mechanism that you're generally going to
be using to do code review with other
people yes
so that I think there's a few answers
all have their uh first thing is you
know if you're building a repository you
know you create a new repository it's
just a new folder of work you know you
do your changes there you can and
repositories can come and go as work is
done so you can say you can have like a
very small project you have a repository
for it and you say okay projects over
that wasn't very interesting and you can
abandon it it's particular issue with
data science work is Jupiter notebooks
Jupiter notebook does not play very
nicely with with a version control right
out of the box and there's not there's
not a super great reason for it not to
do so it decides well the tooling does
exist so there's a yeah you can do that
um I've actually grown less and less I
like to view notebooks as like kind of a
final output versus like where I like to
do a lot of my active development but
that's that's a personal style um there
is a tool called review and be that you
can see actually has these two panes
that show you the differences that are
getting made this is it's a paid product
although if you are working in open
source products they will offer a free
license for that
but if you're if you're in a company you
will have to pay I don't know what their
policy is say for educational or or
government research institutions that
would be something to look into but this
would be actually a very helpful tool to
all of your doing this the other thing
that you're going to be dealing with if
you're dealing with a lot of data
analysis is Excel let me introduce you
to excel trail a similar paint product
again there there isn't a great reason
that excel doesn't need it
handle code code ifs because excels are
basically XML trees there are tools to
diff trees or there sorry there are
algorithms to diff trees they just
haven't really implemented it yet and
Excel to do this but if you're working
in a context where a lot of people are
using Excel which is most commercial
enterprises something like this will
actually point out you know and cell K
51 people have made these changes here
another common issue you might have if
you're doing code work code work is you
know you have like some common code that
you would like to have between different
repositories but you have different
projects from there what I might say
would work then is you might want to put
the common code into a into like a
Python package and then like the common
code cannot be its own repository and
then the other repositories can just
download that package in use so common
instance that I've had is you've written
code that like this is my code that
loads data from our FTP server this is
my code that load stuff from my sequel
this is my code that load stuff from
Postgres this is my code that loads
stuff off of Dropbox you know you just
have a bunch of helper functions in
Python they you know that bit of code
can can be put into a package and then
every other repository you can download
that you can install that package and
then you have all the connectors so that
would be an approach I would take I made
my changes I'm I'm very happy with my
own work don't be happy with your own
work it you know the long and short of
it is it's a it's very easy to fool
yourself it's if you aren't going to do
code review like
you make your changes you step away you
do something else for a while and then
you go back in your review your code
them because that having a fresh set of
eyes is good will be very helpful to
kind of say like oh I made a mistake
there and then you can catch that and
then you know more important having
somebody else look at at what you've
done
they don't have that they don't have the
the same context that confirm this merge
and our changes are reflected here who
should review your your code request
how many area of you are familiar with
get blame small salary smattering of
people you can tell the emotional state
of whoever wrote that command the get
annotate does the same thing you're not
gonna remember get annotate you won't
you will remember get blame get blame
basically tells you requirements dot txt
jet plane will tell you the last time
every every line was changed in your
code so you can see I'm the only person
who's worked on this it's three lines
it'll tell you the time of the commit it
will also give you part of the the
commit hash so if you need to actually
look look for it and get log you can
find when this was done but if I'm
working on a file and I want to say like
okay
who you know who who do I need to tag as
reviewers for this the first thing I
will do is I'll run get blame on the
file and I will see oh you know
so-and-so worked on this they should
probably be reviewers on this code I
don't know if github does this
automatically I know bitbucket will
actually run get blame on the file and
they'll suggest reviewers based on the
[ __ ] blame they'll say hey you know I
see these people have run on this maybe
you should tag them the other approach
is creating what's called a code owners
file yes is not in base kit but github
get lab bitbucket there's a special file
you can create much it looks like a
readme or something but you can tell it
like every file that you knows is in
this folder this is the person who
should review this every file that ends
in dot py you know this guy is our
Python expert or this guy's are our
expert so they should review Python or
our files for exercise so if I was going
to requests so if I don't have a pull
request I can see I will go to this
called pull request tab here new pull
request master compare master that's you
know master there's no difference
between master but I want to add our
dummy microphone so it'll say able to
merge we can see it will show me the
changes that are being made we can click
create pull request we can I can add
reviewers if
if there was anybody with this but since
we don't have anybody for this again yet
will tell us if there's merge conflicts
or not merge conflicts from the merge
and so now looking back at the master
branch we can see we'll see commits for
the for the pull requests that we've
created and we'll see the commits I've
done as well so all this code is now in
the master branch is the code on my
computer know what's the command I would
run to get to pull the code back onto my
computer not merge how do I tell my
computer that there's Remo changes
exactly get fetch I'll make sure I'm on
the correct branch if I just tried get
pull origin master
yeah you I've had an inconsistent
results match but it's a good eye that's
a good habit to have especially if you
need to if you need to grab any new
branch and yeah sometimes sometimes
things just disappear periodically I bet
I know what actually I think I know why
it worked
SourceTree was automatically fetching
for me in the background
so thank SourceTree how do we make a
good pole request there's a really good
book I recommend everybody everybody
read headed edited by Greg Wilson and
Andy harem it's called me making
software basically meta analyses of
different aspects of industrial code
review so what research do we actually
have and what works with with doing code
review what works with you know what
research do we have on on quality
metrics between closed and open source
things fantastic these next few slides
are from their from their chapter on
code review I mentioned before any
faggin said the most productive use of
time for code review the most productive
use of time is go to deal
Cohan in 2006 said the most productive
use of time is the first hour of code
you're fresh for an hour after an hour
you get tired you're not finding errors
you need to take a break consequently if
somebody else needs to review for you if
your pull request is really big and
somebody else needs to look at your code
for multiple hours they're either gonna
have to do it over a series of time or
they're not going to be able to be very
thorough
so one hour of time in terms of lines of
code that tracks you about a few hundred
lines I'm not actually aware if there's
much of a difference if there's a real
language dependency on this the fact
being you do a lot more with 20 lines of
Python than you do with 20 lines of Java
or C but one way or another you need to
have relatively small digestible bites
for people to do and really big
open-source projects people will reject
pull requests that are too big because
they'll say I this is too much for us to
be able to understand all the
ramifications of what's happening in
terms of actually doing code review so
how many of you have had meetings for
code review 2 3 4 5 6 6 people
meetings are good for one thing only and
that's if you have a bug that's really
hard to figure out most of the time just
reading the code and running it on your
own you're able to catch 95% plus of the
of the bugs it's you only need to call a
meeting when something's really subtle
and you're not quite sure what's going
on if you are opening code reviews it is
perfectly fine to have an incomplete
code change open up the code review just
mark it as work in progress or WIP and
just let people know like this isn't
ready yet but I'd like you to look this
over as I say three hours of work that
you have to completely redo is a lot
better than 10 hours of work that you
have to completely review redo being
able to collaborate with people early
especially if it's kind of a bigger
project is going to be is going to save
you a lot of difficulty and a lot of
headache when you find out like oh this
is not remotely what we needed
commits as checkpoints how many people
have seen commit histories that look
like this I've had I've had a couple
worker co-workers that would do that no
you you don't you don't have to do it
every tiny change you know it works
there's a technique called squashing
where use git rebase to basically
combine sets of of PRS together but
trying to kind of keep keeping them out
trying to keep the number of commits to
a reasonable level is very helpful
because if you have kind of a bigger
project one thing I may try doing is
I'll look commit by commit to see all
the changes that were made I mentioned
earlier if you have a really big code
change that you need to make try and do
it as a series of smaller commits before
everything goes back to the to the main
commit at least in this case all these
smaller pull requests that you do
there's it's gonna let people be more
confident that okay you know that in
this in the end of this this has been
four thousand lines of code but we've
more methodically gone through this and
we're reasonably confident that
everything is correct and so we can we
can push this back to master just trying
to trying to do a massive commit
semester I've had coworkers that I've
tried to command something like 10 K
lines of code right before they're about
to leave the company
it it's very endearing it's also very
helpful because oh hey I need to I need
to meet with you to debrief because I'm
taking over your project oh you're very
busy with your giant code merge that you
didn't merge anything for the past six
months
Thanks guess we're not guess I'm not yet
debriefing with you reviewing somebody
else's code there's a really good talk
by NEMA Cherenko this the the title it's
pythonic code reviews this bit li hai
code reviews will it will take you there
that way the long and short of it if
you're reviewing somebody else's code is
don't be a jerk
specifically what does that mean it code
reviews are are an opportunity for
people to to practice to improve their
craft it's not where you should be
talking about how much better of a
reviewer you are it's not an occasion
for you to you know you need to pick and
choose your battles of what what to
nitpick versus you know fix this class
of problems and you know be supportive
it's it's very nice if somebody did
something really good to say like hey
this looks great good job
yeah used to use decorators I learned
something new that way the other thing I
will always suggest if possible if
you're even somebody else's code fetch
that code bring it to your computer and
run it the number of PRS I've been able
to find defects because they did
somebody made a change and they didn't
test that the code worked or their code
works on their computer but they have a
bunch of Python packages that they
didn't that they forgot to add to
require requirements dot txt and I'm not
you know I'm not gonna say I'm
particular greater I've also made that
same mistake of how hard you know I
don't need to test this it's just such a
small change and then I forget a comma
and the code doesn't work but you know
going through the exercise of all right
download this code run the test does it
work does it fail that is a really
important way to be able to say like
this is good code check or no we found
it bug the one exception I've had and in
particular my current company I've had a
real trouble with is sometimes for like
really big data projects that live in
the cloud so you know you're you're
dealing with - you're building a
workflow and processes you know a
terabyte of data you know spark is
chugging along
you might instead of showing like hey
this runs on my computer you'll have to
show like hey here's here's a
demonstration of it running on the
target computer you know maybe instead
of say for data workflows you might
output to a temporary database schema
rather than like the production database
schemas but one way or another either
running on your machine or running on
the target machine but to kind of a
development database these are ways to
show like know this this code works so
we are going to do a code review
together so I have a microphone code so
we have force sensors code that plots
the the force response current we saw
that early on we want to have the same
for the microphone code this is a much
larger bit of code than adding just a
few lines here so I create a title
I get a helpful description if you guys
do you go to the repo you should be able
to see the pull request on your own if
not being able to comment but this code
has errors in it so what what should be
the first thing that we try doing try
and run the code very good
so I created some code there may or may
not have been a lot of copy/paste
happening so I download the code to my
computer and it goes into master images
[Music]
so I go to instruments immigrations so I
tell myself I'm gonna run this
microphone co dot py Mike ID you can run
it on the dummy microphone and we have
an error oh no does anybody see see
what's missing
yep we are missing an equal side here
one really nice thing about yeah one
nice thing vs code is telling me or any
any Python linters they can actually
find these errors for you so I fix it
I run again what force sensor is not
defined
something this hopefully points out we
run again sensor ID is not defined again
this is it's really helpful that a BS
code points this out for me but this you
know this is code that I copy pasted
from the plot for sun source code
because it worked
except that irene rename certain things
this is a very easy thing to trip
yourself up on when you're writing your
own code that's really well obviously
the code works here
why valves phase is not defined does
anybody see what what's happening here
so we're actually we define two splines
but we accidentally overwrite we don't
define the new thing that we need a lot
of a lot of writing code is going to be
is going to be like this okay
we have a plot up here we don't have a
plot here anybody know what the the
error might be for that yes exactly I
didn't change the the axis that I plot
on and as a process of debugging again
you run through things again and again
see these things aren't lining up that's
more subtle error that you might see
here what's what would be an issue with
some of this code that some people might
might point out
it has to do with the equal signs yep
pepete violations consistent spacing is
good I'm generally a fan of peppy you
can run you can use a letter or
something to find these sorts of things
who should fix their could fix her code
formatting sorry could you speak a
little louder the author and why would
that be why should the author fixer code
formatting they should I mean
objectively they should be writing good
code we talked about something earlier
though that if somebody else fixes the
code formatting it's going to change
sorry now I mean it's a code change
exactly you got it if if I go around and
pepete everybody else's code and
somebody runs get blame on the code it
will look like I wrote all the code
because I was the last person to change
the file and you know it's it's a little
frustrating to figure out like okay what
happened here last commit must change
whitespace so I tend to I tend to be a
little aggressive on making people Peppe
their code although it depends on where
you're working in the culture around it
but yet pepete yourself don't pep ate
unto others so I I am making the live
changes as I go along
generally all me I'll try and make the
changes
it I mean partially it depends if it's a
small thing where oh this is a small fix
I'll send it in you know I've been known
to push my own fixes to the code you
know especially if it's like here's one
line I've changed out of you know 50
lines of new code now if you look at the
get blame logs you can see like okay
this was most mostly person's acts code
Paul just fixed one line of this but
yeah as we are going around here we
should be saying adding things like code
start a review just so you know I can
either add a comment and that will be
done if I click on start a review it
will then give github will tell me like
oh you need to somebody needs to address
this comment before everything
everything gets done so that all
comments about ie you can use markdown
as you edit these which is kind of nice
you have two errors should I point them
both out we're using sensor ID in both
places yes now yes
you know it's a little a little
questionable if somebody's making the
same error again and again and again you
know I'll try and say like replace all
instances of sensor ID with microphone
ID or just that's one comment to deal
with rather than getting 10 different
comments as I am going around making my
small changes I tend to I tend to then
add the the edits there last thing we
have time for time for is going to be
issues so issues are kind of a prelude
to a poll request if I'm working in a
you know at my current company we use
JIRA so if there's something I know
code fix we need to make we will use
that but you know what if I wanted to
fix something if I said like hey
something in matplotlib is breaking live
is pretty recent
pretty good but if there was something
that I thought AHA plot new live needed
to fix or if for example I had a
suggestion of something that that needs
needed to be made as an example I was
reading through this book atomic Scala
they have a github page I said hey
here's a couple suggestions I have you
have a little they had a code example
where they were using the circumference
of a circle rather than the area I'm
like hey you know this is pretty good
but you should consider adding a chapter
on on SBT which is kind of
as I understand this call equivalent of
pimp among other things so you know this
is this is a great way to collaborate
with other people if you're at in their
code is I just created an issue so if I
think anybody should be able to create
an issue so if I create an issue tell me
if something's here text this is not a
very informative issue one thing I will
point out is that you see that these
issues are getting are getting numbered
and are pull requests are getting
numbered so we have poor request number
three in github issues and pull requests
share the same numbering system so as
you add issues and pull requests you go
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten it's a little bit different and
get loud and bitbucket but I have issue
number four here and if I create a new
issue
I can giving I can give a number thing
here and I can either refer to a pull
request or I can refer to another issue
so this is a really good way to be able
to especially when you're creating a
pull request you can say like hey we
created this issue we discussed what
might be good or bad with something this
is code that's going to fix that issue
even more so I'm gonna create an issue
that says
have some unit tests for
so we have issue number five if I go to
a pull request they have this unit test
that I want to create I can add fixes
number five and if we go to the issue
you need to actually do this in the
description and then the issue gets
linked here
even better we go through if we approve
this pull request or is it good
if this gets merged in you can actually
depending on how you set up the repo
pull requests might need people to
actually formally click a button to
approve the pull request I've generally
worked at places where you cannot push
directly to master and all pull requests
to master require either one or two
approvals have not set this up like that
here but we can say we've merged this in
it automatically closes the issue so
this is a very helpful way that that
github is able to say like oh we brought
up this thing that we need to fix we've
created the PR it says it fixes it close
the ticket we don't need to get it
anymore I like to do it just because I
don't like having just I don't like
having to scroll through like 50
different branches of you know what's
the branch that correspond to my work so
I tend to clean up branches after I'm
done with them
so the pol repo the pull request for
that thing will still exist even at
they'll be closed and that's tense if I
need to say like okay somebody merged in
these changes I need to kind of
understand the ticket I'll generally go
back to the pull request and I can see
what got changed I don't and you can
look at the you should be able to look
at the commits in the pull request even
if the branch itself has been deleted so
that tends to be what how I handle
things and of course on my on my own
personal computer there's no sense for
me keeping extraneous branches that I
don't need of a slight bit of history
the other thing that may or may not
happen is when you merge your branch
back to the master branch
all commits that came with it get moved
over as well modulo you might I don't
think github lets you do this but and
get lab there's an option to squash all
your commits together so it just has one
commit which is all the changes from
this feature branch should become one
command rather than having multiple
things I like to do that just cuz I
don't like digging through really long
complicated commit histories but that
may be more an issue of preference and
discussion we are running a little bit
low on time there I do want to call out
this really helpful website called
dang it get there's also a much strong a
stronger language version that you can
find but it gives you so much so many
ways to shoot yourself in the foot this
website here gives you about 10 or so
recipes for ok I made this mistake how
do I undo what I've done so if you need
to undo something doing a revert if
you've if you've committed code to the
wrong branch I've done that in fact I
did this here in the tutorial ah you can
you can do that with cherry picking if
you need to undo commits you can use
revert so a very helpful very helpful
site I hope at all it all gives you some
benefit somewhere down the line alright
well thank you everybody for coming
[Applause]